Сутички в Гамбурзі почалися через екстремістів із "Чорного блоку".
Під час маршу "Ласкаво просимо до пекла"
агресивно налаштованій групі з близько тисячі осіб
вдалося прослизнути у лави 12 тисяч мирних демонстрантів.
Вимогу поліції зняти чорні маски
вони бойкотували. Хто ці люди?
"Чорний блок" не має лідерів чи якогось апарату управління.
Це "аморфне" угруповання об'єднує різні анархістські
та екстремістські лівацькі групи.
Назва походить від зовнішнього вигляду учасників руху:
вони вбрані в одяг чорного кольору,
носять чорні кепки та капюшони. А також чорні маски,
що в Німеччині за законом ще з 1985 року
заборонено під час масових акцій.
Завдяки такому "дрес-коду"
їхні особи складно ідентифікувати після сутичок з правоохоронцями
та інших протизаконних дій.
"Чорний блок" виник у Німеччині у 80-х роках.
Відтоді "чорноблочники" вдаються до насильницьких акцій протесту
проти глобального світового устрою.
Вони не лише вступають у сутички з поліцейськими,
а й вдаються до вандалізму, підпалів автівок,
встановлення баррикад.
"Чорний блок" активний не лише в Німеччині,
але й в Австрії, Швейцарії, Італії, США та Єгипті.
Німецька поліція ще напередодні саміту "Великої двадцятки"
попереджала про небезпеку заворушень через екстремістів з "Чорного блоку".
Тисячі інших протестувальників, які виходять у ці дні на вулиці Гамбурга,
мітингують мирно.
Влада міста санціонувала понад 30 різних акцій протесту,
приурочених до саміту G20.